Piaget was very interested in how you
produce structures that enable you to
regulate yourself because you're like a
kind of a,
a colony of strange sub animals that
have to figure out how to get along so
that you can sort of be one thing.
You kind of learned that I would say
between the ages of two and four as
you're being socialized,
you know,
how erratic two year olds are.
I mean,
they're a blast and it's part because
they were erratic.
It's like they're unbelievably happy and
then they're unbelievably hungry and
then they're really hot and then they're
really upset and crying,
you know?
And then they're really scared.
It's like,
and all of that just untrammeled.
And so it's really fun to be around
them,
especially when they're happy because
they're so happy that it's just,
you know,
you don't ever get to be that happy.
And so it's nice to be around the two
year old because you can kinda feel that
again,
you know,
and a lot of what the.
One of the horrible things about being a
parent is that you spend a tremendous
amount of your time making your child
less happy.
And the reason for that is that positive
emotion is a very impulsive,
you know,
and you know because everybody says,
well,
you should be happy.
It's like,
well,
no,
when you're happy you're actually quite
stupid.
And so because happiness makes you
impulsive,
happiness makes happiness.
Says,
hey,
things are really good right now.
Get what you can while the getting's
good.
And so as a like,
if you're hyper optimistic,
manic will say it's like every stock
investment looks like a really good
stock investment.
It's like you go to spend all your money
because look at,
there's those wonderful things
everywhere and you could do such great
things with them and then you know,
you spend all your money and then you
crash and you think,
Oh God,
my life's over,
you know,
because I just,
I just spent all my money on all this
useless stuff.
And it's all under the grip of
impulsive,
positive emotion,
you know?
And so when,
when you're telling your kids to be
quiet and settled down,
it isn't because they're making a lot of
noise being in pain is because they're
running around like wild baboons having
a blast and disrupting things like mad,
you know,
you got kids,
you got to settle down,
you know,
like quit having so much fun and it's
kind of awful that you do that.
But,
but you do.
And that's because the emotions and the
motivations have to be brought into a
relationship with one another within the
person.
So that,
you know,
one thing I remember with my son who is
quite,
he's quite disagreeable by temperament,
which is actually a good thing as far as
I'm concerned,
although it brings its own challenges.
And so with my daughter when she was
misbehaving,
she was pretty agreeable and uh,
you know,
if she was misbehaving I could basically
just look at her and then she'd quit.
But my son,
it was like,
that was just nothing.
You're looking at me.
It's like,
no,
that's just not gonna go anywhere man.
And so then I'd tell them to stop and
that really wasn't having much of an
effect either.
He just sort of maybe laugh or runaway
or whatever.
I mean he was a tough little rat and you
know,
what I would do with him is he would be
doing something and it interfered and
he'd get upset and you know,
angry.
And so then I get them to sit on the
steps and I told them this is when he
was about to.
I said,
look,
you're going to sit on the steps.
That's time out.
You're going to sit on the steps until
you've got control of yourself and you
can come back and be and play the game
again.
I basically said,
be a civilized human being and then
you're welcome again.
And so he'd sit on the steps.
It was so interesting to watch because
he was just enraged.
He'd sit there like,
have you ever seen a two year old have a
temper tantrum?
It's really quite the bloody phenomena.
If you ever saw an adult do that,
you'd like,
you'd call nine one one right away.
And it's like,
Oh my God,
I've seen adults do that,
you know,
because people say with borderline
personality disorder will have temper
tantrums and it's like,
man,
you want to be about 30 feet away from
that person.
That's for sure.
It's really.
But in kids it's like,
well first of all,
they're only this long.
So how much trouble can they really
cause?
But it's like,
you know,
they're just completely gone there.
Like on the floor of their face is red.
They're just furious,
like way more furious than you ever get
if you are even vaguely socialized
there,
just outraged.
And they're kicking and hitting the
ground and like it's like a little
epileptic fit of anger,
you know,
they're completely controlled by their
rage.
And we took care of one kid for awhile
who he was actually a pushover,
that kid,
you could get them to behave by,
you know,
kind of shaking your finger at him.
But his mother thought he was really
tough because he had her,
he had her figured out and one of the
things he would do is have a temperature
temper tantrum.
And during the temper Tantrum,
he would hold his bloody breath until he
turned blue.
It's like,
try that,
like you know,
as that's your homework,
go home and go home and have a temper
tantrum and while you're doing it,
hold your breath until you actually turn
blue.
It's like you won't be able to do it.
You don't have the willpower of a two
year old now.
That's for sure.
That little varmint man,
he just have a fit.
Then he'd hold his breath and then he'd
turned blue.
It was like,
wow,
that's,
that's amazing.
And we would just like,
let them do it and you know,
he turned blue and everybody would be
gone and he'd come out of it,
you know,
and it didn't work.
So he just quit doing it.
I think he did it like twice and he
figured out,
oh well that's a lot of work for very
little outcome.
And you know,
it's not like two year olds are stupid.
They're not stupid.
They're probably smarter than you,
but they're not civilized by any stretch
of the imagination.
And so anyways,
back to my son,
I'd put them on the steps and he'd be
like,
oh,
it's just like aged and trying to get
himself together,
you know?
And I wait a few,
few,
I got a strict rule which was as soon as
you're done,
you're welcome again.
So it's completely under your control.
You,
you get yourself calmed down,
you come and talk to me again.
If you're calm enough.
So I like you,
then you're welcome back in the family.
No grudge or nothing.
And so it's harder than you think.
Like people think they liked their kids.
It's like don't be thinking that they're
hard to like they're little monsters and
they're very,
very pushy and provocative.
And so lots of parents do not like their
children and they do terrible things to
them their whole life.
So it's no joke and it's a very common.
And you know,
that was Freud's observation,
fundamental observation that a lot of
psychopathology is rooted in the family
and you can be sure of that.
You know when,
when you hear about some mother who's
done something terrible to her child,
which happens reasonably frequently,
you know perfectly well that she has a
very terrible capacity to discipline.
The child is just provoked or unprovoked
or provoked or unprovoked or provoked
her and it just happens to be a day
where her new boyfriend left and she's
quite hungover and she got fired and
it's like that's the wrong data
provoker,
and then she does something that is not
good and you read about it and you
think,
well,
how could that happen?
How could anyone do that?
Well,
that's how they do it,
and so and kids are very provocative.
Just like little chimps.
Chimps will.
The adolescents will like throw little
pebbles and sticks out the sleeping
larger males and bug them and that
teasing,
which it is,
that teasing turns into full fledged
dominance,
challenged behavior.
Once the adolescent males get big enough
to do it,
and so when you're being provoked by a
child,
which they provoke your time,
they're trying to figure out,
well,
just where are you exactly?
What happens if I do this?
What happens if I do this,
you know,
and how else are they going to figure it
out?
Anyways,
he'd sit on the steps and just,
it's just enraged and trying to control
himself and I've watched that and then,
you know,
I come back after about two minutes or
whatever and he'd still be around.
I'd say,
well are,
you know,
have,
have you got yourself under control?
Are you ready to get off the steps?
Go,
no,
not yet.
And then,
you know,
he'd get himself under control and then
he'd come back and you know,
he'd be contrite and then I would like
him right away.
You know,
you to watch that,
you know,
because you don't like being dominated
by a two year old,
no one does.
And so if the child hasn't mastered
himself and started to act in accordance
with the prevailing social norms,
you won't like them while you think,
oh yeah,
I will because you know,
I'm a good person.
It's like,
no,
you won't and no,
you're not a good person.
So don't be thinking about that at all.
It's just not true.
So when he was contrite,
then he'd come and then we just go on
like nothing had happened because that's
what you want to do,
right?
As soon as you get compliance,
especially if the compliance is in the
best interest of the child,
you want to reward it instantly,
right?
That's the right thing to do because so
then,
and you could just see him gaining
control over himself.
And so really what was happening is his,
in his mind,
in his brain will say there was a war
between the psyche,
the ego that was starting to become
integrated and starting to become a
continuous person,
an identity,
and it's fragile in two year olds and it
can be disrupted all the time.
And it is.
That's why they're so hyper emotional.
It's fragile,
that little ego and it doesn't have a
lot of power.
And so what you want to do is reward it
when it wins,
you know,
it's when it,
when he gets control over the underlying
motivations,
you want to say,
hey,
good work man,
good work kid.
You did it.
You know,
you got yourself under control way to
be.
And the kids really happy about that
because it's actually not that much fun
to have a temper tantrum.
It's exhausting,
you know,
it takes you over.